[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up
mkbhd here and if you're looking for the
most elaborate possible way
to lose your wireless charging i think
we might have found it this is a custom
backed
iphone 12 pro with a crazy design by a
certain company
called caviar and we've seen crazy
custom caviar iphones before right
they're calling this one space odyssey
moon and the theme here
is all about space so from the unboxing
experience you just saw with the lights
and the stars
to the phone itself so all this metal
you see here is steel and titanium
and it kind of just looks like this
illustration of a starry night sky
and something about it being on the the
flat back of the iphone 12
with the flat sides and everything and
the exact
depth of the camera being taken up by
this canvas
kind of feels more like an art piece
basically and as i hold it there is
absolutely added weight here it's
heavier and a little thicker than just
the regular iphone by itself
and the texture at the bottom is
significantly raised so the craters
i guess is what you'd call them uh you
can feel every single one of them you
can run your finger over it
and fill everything and then in the
middle of the bottom
apparently in this little bubble here is
a piece of the moon like a real piece
of the act how did how do you get a
see this is i don't know that sounds
rare right i don't know if that's really
rare but
caviar is selling this on their site uh
for
six thousand nine hundred forty dollars
which is crazy but
i don't know like a real piece of them
i have no way of verifying or even
knowing if that
could end up in you know what
i know who to talk to about this
[Music]
yo neil what's up man marcus
yeah how you been man i'm doing all
right thanks for the time on such short
notice
i um i have some some questions about
some stuff well i hope i can answer them
so okay so let me just start with like
because you would know this
okay how do pieces of the moon
end up on earth yeah well there are
three ways you can do it
one of them is that you go there
scoop up some material and bring it back
the six
apollo missions that landed on the moon
all brought back
satchels of rocks another way are on
sample return
missions that don't even involve
astronauts you can send a spacecraft to
the moon it'll do some scooping and then
it'll launch back
and then you collect it got it the third
way and this way
exceeds all other rocks ever brought to
earth from the moon
is from asteroid strikes on the moon
itself
so you see what the moon looks like
right it's completely pockmarked there's
no
atmosphere to burn up most of what falls
to it
so you have one asteroid striking the
surface of the moon with such
energy that a shock wave builds in the
surrounding regions and it flings rocks
into space
and some of those rocks will achieve
escape velocity from the moon
they'll just leave the moon entirely and
then they're wandering
in space in the earth moon system
eventually 100 of those rocks
will collide with earth now the smaller
ones will burn up and you'll see them as
like a shooting star
at night you say wasn't that cool that
could have been moon dust
the larger pieces are will survive their
trip through the atmosphere
and land on the earth so but you do the
calculations there's tons of moon rocks
that got here
by that method oh wow tons okay well let
me so
is there a way to verify
that a a meteorite you might have is
definitely from the moon okay so
i have colleagues who are in the
business of verifying whether
what you found is a meteorite an
authentic meteorite at all
whether or not it's from the moon and
they have this saying it's called most
people have
meteor wrongs okay you see this odd
looking rock because you think that's
what meteors look like
and then you bring it in there's we used
to have a meteor identification day
meteorite identification day and most
rocks you think
are meteorites or not so you would do a
chemical analysis of it
if you if it was another not otherwise
obvious to a meteorite specialist
you can do a chemical analysis if it's
heavy in iron it's
it's definitely not from the moon's
surface which has
barely any metals at all
so there are ways to figure it out but
we only know that because we've been to
the moon
and we know what that sample looks like
and then we get to compare ah
got it okay uh there's a reason for all
these moon questions
sorry i didn't even yeah i'm wondering
like wait what
are you hankering for some moon dust
what's your thing
yeah so there's this this iphone right
here this is a it's a custom
phone okay and uh it's got this this art
piece on the back and it's it's
beautiful it's very space themed i think
you'd like it
but um the piece i'm curious about is
down here at the bottom
there is a claimed very tiny piece
of the moon on the back of this phone
and i'm just trying to figure out if
it's
possible that that's actually what this
is okay so
it's a really tiny piece of the moon
okay
so the rules are i'm just saying with
the rules not the reality the rule is
the the apollo astronauts who brought
back moon rocks that is all
in the possession of the united states
government okay
at nasa and the smithsonian so
technically you're not
supposed to have access to that right
but
like i said whatever we brought back
from the moon
pales compared to the tonnage of rocks
that have come from the moon naturally
so you can open up meteor cattle
meteorite catalogs and some of them will
be
lunar and some will be martian and uh
you can buy them
so you could sell you know 100 000
iphones with a microgram of moondust in
it
using a pound of moon dust and and that
sounds like
it's a you can make a lot of money that
way now now
i i don't value carrying around moon
dust
it'd be fun if i had a rock yeah but
here's one microgram that's embedded in
this thing in my
iphone this maybe it's bragging rights i
don't know
but um it but let me just say it does
look cool what you held up
looks kind of cool yeah it's to me the
question is number one
could it really be a piece of the moon
sounds like yes
but then number two is the price so how
much
would you actually charge for something
like this this phone
they're charging six thousand nine
hundred and
twenty dollars for yeah so that's okay i
would expect that
so if you look at the prices of
meteorites you can buy one
that's within your budget it's just
depending what size you you you want to
get it at so
so i've seen meteorite catalogs there
they're around and they're
arizona they're they're companies based
in in places where
so there's much less mars dust
that's known and if you find one that
has mars dust on it i think that'd be
kind of a way i'd rather have it as its
own conversation piece because one day
you're going to throw away that iphone
okay because the next iphone is going to
come out
and so that's it'd be odd to put
something so interesting
on what is amounted to a disposable item
ah and that is what i want to talk about
sorry neil
but see i don't have the tools to cut
this
open and determine if it's actually a
piece of the moon but the consensus
is you can buy and sell a piece of the
moon meteorites for up to about a
thousand dollars a gram
this might as well be a piece of the
moon but at this point
three videos in i'm not even interested
in
this custom iphone anymore so much as
i'm trying to figure out caviar this is
actually
the third video i've made about a
ridiculous
caviar custom iphone because they
decided to reach out
and send one to the studio and i'm not
even going to call out any other fellow
you know youtube creators but if you
just look through youtube and search for
any other custom
or gold or crazy expensive iphone
youtube is filled with glorious
thumbnails and crazy headlines and
almost
all of those videos are about a caviar
iphone so if my natural question is what
is the point of this stuff and why do
they keep sending
me and other fellow tech youtubers these
caviar iphones
the answer is because we'll keep making
videos about them if you send
a crazy hundred thousand dollar gold
iphone
to someone who makes videos about phones
for a living
you're probably going to get a video of
someone posing with it and a crazy
thumbnail and it's probably just a
channel for free marketing again if
you're caviar it's kind of a no-brainer
right
you cross your fingers that hopefully
they link back to your site but
basically
all press is good press right so the
other question is just
who is actually buying these things like
i actually think
it's really cool that there are people
out there making
cool custom art pieces with a piece of
the moon
and let's say we give them the benefit
of the doubt that it is a real piece of
the moon
and i even think it's pretty cool that
it's on the back of an iphone 12 pro and
it like fits perfectly over this
rectangular shape and they thought a lot
about this layout
it's impressively well built like i said
the flat sides of the iphone make it
look
more well integrated than ever but
what's the point of attaching it to a
working
iphone and then actually selling it like
someone might
use this phone well it turns out the
more you look into caviar global
as a company the more it all starts to
make sense their russian company
they make a lot of uh luxury
tech products and they thrive
they absolutely thrive on headlines
they're like everything the escobar
company
wanted to be so instead of gluing a gold
sticker to the back of a galaxy fold
caviar mostly focuses on heavily
customizing
iphones so they sell an iphone with a
piece of the moon in it as you can see
sure they also have a six thousand
dollar iphone with a piece of
mars in it they have one with a piece of
mercury there's a ten thousand dollar
iphone with a piece of
the first apple one computer and a
hundred
twenty thousand dollar gold on gold
iphone they also make
a fifteen thousand dollar gold
american flag trump biden
phone which is even weirder
coming from russia and their latest
edition which you might have seen
headlines on
is an iphone 12 with a custom back with
a piece of
steve jobs original turtleneck
in the logo of the phone
okay and then on their site instead of a
couple of dumb obviously paid videos on
a youtube channel
they've got a whole page on their site
of famous clients
ranging from hockey's alexander ovechkin
to boxing's roy jones jr
to other russian politicians and
olympians basically all of them
with some sort of caption that they
receive this gift
as a gift for their new russian
citizenship or their alignment with
russian politics and also
super weird but if you google like i did
if you got super into this and you
actually look up each of these people
the photo that is on caviar's site of
them like posing with the phone like
that
is the only photo i can find of each of
these people
with any caviar iphone like you can try
this yourself google
alina zayatova caviar nothing else comes
up just caviar's picture
google roy jones jr caviar there's one
article
with that same one blurry photo for the
whole entire internet if you google
alexander ovechkin
caviar well he's a hockey player and
apparently he filled up the stanley cup
with caviar after he won it and ate out
of it so that came up
before any caviar phone now look unlike
the whole
escobar inc thing i don't actually know
anyone or have ever seen anyone who's
actually
tried to buy one of these caviar phones
or or accessories or lighters or airpods
or any of the stuff they make
so i'm not here to tell you that it's a
scam or anything like that
but what i'm here to tell you is number
one
it's kind of weird to spend thousands of
dollars
on a brand new phone and it arrives
already set up and turned on out the box
just for like a wallpaper
the only other people i've seen do that
is actually escobar and then number two
aside from the the precious metals like
gold
and and diamonds there's no way for
me and most regular people to ever
verify the authenticity of any of the
things they're claiming whether it's
a piece of the moon or a piece of mars
or a piece of steve jobs original
turtleneck and even if it is actually
that thing
it's still pretty overpriced like if
anything here is obvious it's that
people shouldn't be buying this stuff
for value but there are collectors out
there and collectors actually care
more about limited editions to preserve
low supply
than anything else so everything caviar
makes is always like one of a small
number
this one here is one of 19 for pieces of
the moon phones
and the only real reason they have for
constantly attaching this stuff
to new iphones and pieces of tech it's a
constant
free supply of new hype and
headlines and youtube videos because if
there's one thing we know for sure it's
people
are always talking about the newest tech
so if you
try to put yourself in caviar shoes and
you want to make a crazy expensive super
limited edition little art piece
and you want free marketing to go with
it you should attach that art piece
to the most talked about new tech
product of every year
the iphone and people will talk about it
so there you go
you know after this video caviar they'll
probably email me again
probably ask for the phone back like
usual i'll send it back
and they'll probably never send another
caviar
phone here again although
maybe if they have that same
stubbornness
that we've seen from companies like
escobar inc
maybe they do realize maybe they'll
actually think all press
is good press and they'll keep just just
spamming that send button to as many
youtubers as possible because
kind of works anyway in the meantime if
you want a custom iphone
just grab an icon skin i'll link it
below it's way cheaper
if you want a piece of the moon just
buy a piece of the moon i guess either
way
that's been it thanks for watching catch
you guys in the next one
peace